in the long term AI may become
autonomous and take over the world but
in the short term it's being used by
politicians to control what you think to
end your independent judgment and erase
democracy on the eve of a presidential
election Elon Musk is very worried about
that
he told us about his plan to stop it
[Music]
what's happening is they're training the
AI July yes it's bad it's a lie that's
exactly right and to withhold
information July and and yes and
um
yeah exactly to to either you know
comment on something it's not comments
on other things but but not to say what
it what what the data uh actually uh
demands that I'd say exactly um so
um how did it get this way you funded it
at the beginning what happened yeah well
that'll be ironic but Faith the most
ironic outcome is most likely it seems
um
that's good the session of a friend of
mine Jonah came up with that one I
actually have a slight variant on that
which is the most entertaining outcome
is the most likely but that's
entertaining as viewed from a third
party viewer like so if we're like an
alien yes
um like you could go see a movie about
World War one and they bring blown to
bits into gas and everything in the
trenches and it's like you're eating
popcorn and having a soda you know it's
fine not so great for the people in the
movie True this little Occam's razor the
simplest explanation is most likely
Jonas variant which is um irony in and
my variant which is uh
the most entertaining as seen by a
third-party audience which seems to be
mostly true
um but it seems true in this case so you
gave them did you give them a lot I
can't with the name and uh the concept
and pushed uh it had a number of dinners
around the the Bay Area uh with uh you
know with some of the people the leading
figures in AI
um
and I helped recruit the initial team in
fact the the aliasis guy who who was uh
really quite fundamental to the success
of uh openai uh it was
I I I put a trans amount of effort into
recruiting Ilia and he changed his mind
a few times ultimately decided to go
with the over knee high but if he had
not gone without any open air would not
have succeeded I really put a lot a lot
of effort into creating this this
organization to serve as a counterweight
to Google
and then I kind of took my off the ball
I guess and uh
they are now closed source
and
they are obviously for-profit and
they're
um
closely allied with Microsoft uh you
know in effect Microsoft uh
has a very strong say if not
um
directly controls uh openai at this
point so you really have an open-air
Microsoft situation and then at Google
deepmind uh the other two sort of
heavyweights in this Arena
so it seems like the world needs a third
option
yes
so I I I think I will
create a third option
um although I was starting very late in
the game of course
can it be done I don't know I think it's
we'll we'll see it's uh
it's definitely starting late
um
but I will I will I'll try to create a
third option
um and that third option
hopefully does more more good than harm
uh like the intention with opening eye
was obviously to do good but it's not
clear whether it's actually doing good
or whether it's
I can't tell at this point um except
that I'm worried about the fact that uh
it's been it's being trained to be
politically correct which is simply
another way of of being on Truth saying
untruthful things yes so that's that's a
bad sign
there's certainly a path to AI dystopia
is to train an AI to be deceptive so
yeah I'm going to start something which
I know you're called Truth gbt or uh a
maximum truth seeking AI
that tries to understand the nature of
the universe and I think this this might
be the best path to Safety in the sense
that uh an AI that cares about
understanding the universe uh it is
unlikely to annihilate humans because we
are an interesting part of the universe
uh hopefully they would think that I I
think you know because yeah like like we
like Humanity could
um decide to hunt down all the
chimpanzees and kill them but we don't
because we're we're actually glad that
they exist yes and um and we aspire to
protect their habitats but we feel that
way because we have souls and that makes
us sentimental and reflective it gives
us a moral sense
longings can a machine ever have those
things can a machine be sentimental
can appreciate Beauty
well I mean we're getting into some
you know philosophical areas that are
hard to resolve
um
you know I I take somewhat of a
scientific view view of things which is
that we might have a soul or we might
not have a soul I don't know
um it feels like a we have I feel like
I've got some sort of
Consciousness that exists on a plane
that is not the one we observe yes that
is certainly how I feel but it could be
an illusion I don't know
um but for
um
for AI uh in terms of of uh
understanding beauty is it some sort of
appreciated Beauty and being able to
um
create incredibly beautiful art yes will
AI be able to create incredibly
beautiful art it already does yes and if
you see some of the majority uh I have
this stuff it's incredible it is
um so
um no question that it can create art
that we that we perceive as uh
stunning really
um
and it's doing sort of still images now
but it won't be long before it's doing
uh movies and
shorts and you know like movies just a
series of frames with audio but at that
point because it can mimic people and
voices any image it can mimic reality
itself so effectively
I mean how could you have a criminal
trial
I mean how could you ever believe that
evidence was authentic for example
and I don't mean like in 30 years I mean
like next year I mean that seems totally
disruptive to the way to all of our
institutions but I'm not sure I I think
it's more like
um our you know will Humanity control
its Destiny or not will we have a future
that is better than the past or not
will Humanity control its future or not
and in the meantime how will this be
used to control us if you've played
around with the latest versions of AI
you will learn it prefers to end the
world with nuclear Armageddon before you
use naughty words so those are its
priorities
Elon Musk is a strong believer in free
speech so strong that he purchased
Twitter a company he didn't need and
hasn't profited from as a way to restore
free speech to the internet to bring us
back say six years to the free country
we lived in then and once he bought
Twitter he discovered it wasn't really a
social media application it was really a
tool for Global intelligence agencies
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight